cauchemar en cuisine qui est de retour
sur m6 ça fonctionne toujours aussi
légère baisse juste hier avec 2 millions
300 mille téléspectateurs leader sur les
femmes responsables des achats ces deux
commerciales les plus importantes pour
m6 est troisième de la soirée hier soir
donc ça vient quand même en globalement
2004 ce mythe c'est très correct alors
vous connaissez le principe samuel de
ses missions que puisque vous regardez
pas la télé où je vous explique de quoi
on parle et c'est important ce qui donc
un cuisinier de renom qui vient aider
des restaurants qui sont un petit peu
dans la difficulté il a un ton bien à
lui
il ya un petit peu il est un petit peu
voilà il épouse dans leurs
retranchements
je veux et de sauver la restauration de
la faillite sauf que après enquête et on
sait qu'aujourd'hui il ya trente
restaurants sauver alors qu'il ya eu 55
émission fait donc ses états en gros 50
% à ces endroits
voilà donc est ce que c'est un bon ratio
ou pas on a mené l enquête regarder on
en parle juste après cauchemar en
cuisine l'émission star de m6 a fait sa
rentrée mercredi soir en prime
le programme est plutôt en forme avec
pratiquement 2,4 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est qui le chef dans
cette cuisine c'est qui le chef de
chevet est cartonne niveau audience donc
créative d'aussi bourgi france qui
concerne les sauvetages de restaurants
et bien sûr les 55 restaurant que
l'émission et ça laisse courir depuis le
début le chef a réussi à en sauver 30 en
chine michael là non pas du tout chef
mais 30 sur 55 ça fait plus de 1 sur 2
c'est pas mal bon c'est vrai ça fait
quand même 25 restaurateurs qui restent
sur le carreau
ça me fait chier enfin lancre limon
malgré tous ces efforts les missions ne
peut empêcher la fermeture de certains
établissements
mais la chaîne l'assument dans son
spin-off que sont ils devenus
on a revu un couple de restauratrice
mélanie et elodie qui a fini par mettre
la clé sous la porte et la séquence a
été jouée à l'antenne qu'est ce qui
s'est passé après votre venue bain
moi je voyais pas d'avancer à l'envoyer
pas non plus donc on s'est dit ben on va
arrêter là toutes les deux alors selon
vous avoir sauvé 30 établissements sur
est ce un bon bilan pour le chef
etchebest et l'émission alors ça
m'aurait étonné que j'ai verdez inouïe
mais on va commencer par vous non ils
sont tombés dans le piège c'est à dire
que maintenant cette émission ce n'est
que de l'outrance et il arrive dans des
restaurants sinistrés désespéré à
l'image de la dernière émission
donc c'est déjà quasiment perdu avant
même de commencer et donc ils sont
victimes de sa et forcément ils sont
insolvables ces restaurants mais c'est
parce que l'émission c'est tellement usé
qu'à mon avis maintenant elle devrait
disparaître pas télévisée long mais leur
art dont ça fonctionne bien
non mais c'est que de l'autre on sait
qu'il est le tour de gordon ramsey grc à
peu près 75 pour son bâton dit j'ai
recommandé que depuis 2015 le taux de
réussite est de 74% la société libanaise
qui s'occupe ensuite de gérer les
restaurants les suivre pendant six mois
et vous avez philippe etchebest qui
souvent les propriétaires au téléphone
parce que c'est un coup de pouce c'est
pas non plus de baguette magique
oui voilà c'est ce que m'a dit match
aller alors oui benjamin pardon c'est un
bilan excellent on parle de restaurants
qui sont à l'agonie à l'origine il
arrive alors effectivement c'est très
scénarisé c'est un peu toujours la même
chose mais c'est formidable qui peut
dire qu'on se lasse on ne se lasse pas
on a limitant des dons vers un resto
pour qu'il me crie dessus
moi j'ai envie qui moussent fille
et qu'on mette rapidement ça nous est là
mais non mais je trouve que je trouve
qu'il est fort sauf que c'est un vrai
personnage sauver 30 restaurants qui
sont on parle quand même de restaurants
qui ne sait pas quel est le taux de
faillite sous le nom de commerce n'est
pas un établissement est mis en
redressement j'ai pas combien sont
sauvés mais ne l'a pas être beaucoup en
moyenne
paris un restaurant lancé tient deux ans
donc c'est passé il ya risque romanum
vous vous aimez pas si j'aime non mais
je trouve que ses vues et revues
oui je sais philippe etchebest un bon
animateur pour vous c'est un peu
répétitif on dirait que c'est vrai
candidat rit ça va bien des manières
moi j'ai douté salsa à chaque fois la
même chose un gros problème c'est
qu'effectivement il ya un tas de
restaurateurs qui s'improvisent
restaurateurs et qui m'ouvre un
restaurant il ya aussi dans les
animateurs malheureusement marquettois
trimestre comme ça à la cantonade
toujours par toujours de de production
qui utilisent les gens ou des sociétés
pour faire de l'audience
moi je dis bravo quand même à studio 89
et la production de cauchemar en cuisine
parce qu'il faut quand même le dire il
bon tu l'as dit aussi visu ils prennent
une société privée avec qui son
partenariat pour gérer après les
restaurants dans lesquels ils sont allés
pendant six mois at il paye avec
philippe esteves qui fait ça aujourd'hui
qui continue et son clip que ça vaut
montrer même le tournage de l'émission
qui fait ça aujourd'hui
franchement bravo à eux
[Applaudissements]
même si on en souffre mais celle que
trois pour moi c'est déjà pas si mal
oui bien sûr donc c'est indécent
personnes qui ont commencé
c'est pas la surnommer mois j'exècre ce
programme vous le savez je le dis à
chaque fois c'est de la mauvaise télé
réalité philippe etchebest il est
enfermé maintenant dans son personnage
tout le temps à gueuler pour un oui pour
un non
je ne supporte pas et ça fonctionne
parce qu'ils gueulent malheureusement
donc je pense qu'il a encore de beau
jour de mai c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on
aime
tu disais mais ça soit 33 restaurants
sauvé sur 50 c'est un bon bilan après
que vous aimiez pas le personnage je
l'entends vous n'ayez pas l'émission je
l'entends mais 33 restaurants non plus
c'est très difficile mais il faut saluer
tous ces entrepreneurs c'est très
difficile mais bon on va demander à la
voie de la sagesse
mais les girondins n'ont plus vraiment
non c'est pas ça c'est juste ce qu il a
dit bernard c'est s'improvise les mecs
maxime haussier de la dce c'est très dur
à monta restaurant il faut se lever le
matin et à 4h pour la régie sous
ailleurs chargé de ces produits à métro
je ne sais où il faut choisir les bons
fournisseurs il faut choisir une bonne
brigade un bon chef il faut être
passionné de vouloir donner à manger aux
gens et vouloir donner du bonheur aux
gens et faute dans sa boutique de 4
heures du matin parfois jusqu'à minuit
1h vous avez des vedettes ils sont venus
s'agit pas juste de poser du fric et
dire je m'offrais à restaurer les
copains venaient manger chez moi
personne paye champagne c'est pas comme
ça que ça fonctionne depardieu et le var
restaurant ça passe ça a marché avec son
nom ça marchait que son nom mais ce
johnny l'ovaire des restaurants ça n'a
pas marché il ya plein de stars avec
leur jeu idiot grand restaurant
jonathan avoir du fric donc que les
missions que l'émission à l'ensemble
c'est vrai que là c'est pareil kg mais
que l'émission se fera non mais j'ai une
estimation c'est qu'a perdu c'est
surtout miraculeux vu dans l'île dans
quel état le reste de l'émission 1 sauf
30 les messins n'est pas là pour sauver
si si tu citais une brêle tim brent ses
baskets cauchemar en cuisine ils vont
venir qui vont venir kimbrel aventure